quality or quantity which is best when
it comes to YouTube If you increase the
quantity of videos that you post you
increase the opportunity for feedback
phase three is how can we not just do
quality but also increase the quantity
through leverage we're going to talk
about three tips that will settle this
question once and for all
this question has kept creators up at
night has caused lives to be lost has
caused people to go into an endless
cycle of Despair and worry and
uncertainty because there is not an
answer to this one question the question
is quality or quantity which is best
when it comes to YouTube some would say
just upload as many videos as possible
and eventually one will pop off others
would recommend that you spend extreme
amounts of time polishing the perfect
video so who's right who's wrong and
what ultimately is the answer the truth
is the answer to this question differs
depending on the season of YouTube that
you're in and in this episode of the
think media podcast we're going to talk
about three tips that will settle this
question once and for all now I gotta
give credit where credit is due and I
recently heard Alex hermosi's answer to
this question and I thought about that
in comparison to my own experience and
realized I think he's got it that's
exactly right and so let's break it down
phase one quantity the best answer if
you are just starting is always going to
be quantity and not quality here's why
if you are truly just starting on
YouTube chances are you may not even
fully know what you want to talk about
yet you don't have any camera skills you
haven't really figured out your voice
you don't have much experience creating
content now to argue this point you
could point to a Creator who starts a
brand new channel and from day one
they're bringing a high level of quality
but I would argue they probably have
previous experience elsewhere maybe
they've had another Channel maybe
they've had an acting career maybe they
have a media company backing them a lot
of times if you start with quality you
actually aren't starting from zero but
assuming you are starting from zero and
video is new to you and YouTube is new
to you quantity is absolutely the best
strategy for phase one this gives you
two things it gives you practice and it
gives you feedback from the audience
many people have heard the story of Mr
Beast who talks about how he uploaded
200 terrible videos before he started to
get real momentum on YouTube if you look
at the gaming Creator PewDiePie he
uploaded hundreds of videos before he
started to get momentum and when you ask
either of those creators how they feel
about their first videos they would tell
you the video sucked they were terrible
they were really bad but I was getting
practice I was getting experience I was
learning the process of creating videos
and I was learning the skills necessary
for being a content creator so in Phase
One quantity is better than quality
because the more reps you can put in the
quicker you can develop your skills the
second benefit is you actually get
feedback from your audience let's say
you already have some momentum or some
skills but you're still not quite sure
which topics or which content formats
are going to resonate if you increase
the quantity of videos that you post you
increase the opportunity for feedback
let's say eventually you get to 100
videos now you can go and look back and
say okay which topics out of these
videos resonated with people the most
which one's got the most comments which
ones perform the best and what can I
learn from those what you're getting is
invaluable feedback from your audience
or invaluable feedback from the market
because phase one is testing and the
more tests you can do in terms of
quantity the better creators that have
entered phase two typically have 30 50
100 200 videos under their belt and now
they've assessed their videos they've
grown some skills they've practiced
they've gotten the audience feedback and
they make a pivot to say okay maybe I'm
not gonna do a challenge to upload a
video every day for 31 days maybe I'm
gonna slow down a little bit
identify the topics that have resonated
most take the skills that I've learned
and apply them to making some Banger
polished YouTube videos the re reason
you can create quality is because of the
insights you learned in the quantity
stage and so my question for you is
which phase are you in do you need to be
taking more massive messy action
uploading more videos analyzing the
results and continuing to build your
skills or have you reached phase two
where you should slow down and actually
invest your skills your learnings your
understanding of YouTube your
understanding of video creation of
communication into one video that maybe
takes a week to make one video that
maybe takes a month to make a story
comes to mind of when I did a four-part
series on how to make a YouTube video
but I didn't just rush through this
series I made four distinct Parts on
Preparation shooting editing and then
uploading I planned it out scripted it
out multiple sets multiple different
locations and I ultimately then uploaded
one video a week for four weeks going
into the series I had a feeling that the
series would do incredibly well and each
episode in the series got hundreds of
thousands of views which was good for
the content that I typically created it
was outperforming everything else why
because I slowed down to invest in
quality furthermore I went into this
process knowing that I was going to
actually combine that four-part series
into a super long video we call them
content marathons and that video has now
generated millions of views what's the
punch line this wasn't just an upload
daily Vlogs as much as I can in YouTube
shorts all the time this was about
slowing down investing in quality and
because of these skill sets and practice
and learning and my understanding of
even what the audience wanted I went
into that four-part series and one super
long video knowing that it was going to
do well of course there's always risk
and mystery around will it do really
well but once the content Marathon got a
couple million views I was like yeah
it's exactly the plan like that's what I
was going for I could have never had
those insights how had I not graduated
from phase one quantity into phase two
quality but my friend we're not done
because there is a third phase and the
third phase is quality and quantity at
this stage you not only know how to make
amazing videos but now you can make more
of them now for the solo Creator this
might be an unreachable goal but if you
start to build your team if you start to
collaborate or have different content
creators involved if you have invested
in editors or team or systems then there
is no reason why you can't do a lot of
videos and also have the quality of them
be great typically that's going to be
impossible if you're a one man or a
one-woman band but as you grow if you've
done a lot of videos and broke through
started to make quality videos got
monetized started to build up your
YouTube business now you could reinvest
your revenues and reinvest your profits
in team in systems to not just increase
quality but also increase increase
quantity you know I think about think
media and obviously it's easier to
create a lot of good videos on think
media when Omar is creating videos and
Nolan's creating videos and I'm creating
videos and so that's a team thing though
there are systems around that at think
media right now we post 350 pieces of
content a week now you might say some of
the stuff that you're posting is not the
greatest quality and I would agree like
there are some clips that are a seven or
maybe a six and a half like our scoring
system is kind of like if it's at least
like a six and a half at the lowest a
six but if the video is a seven eight
nine or a ten then let's post it like
but if it's a four or a three if it's a
five we should leave it on The Cutting
Room floor like the quality is too low
because we want people to at least get
some good information some good
education and how you Define quality and
quantity is different in education our
Niche uh it's content value not
necessarily production value or even
entertainment value people come to learn
a lot of the videos we create we're not
meant to be viral videos they're
educational videos just like this it's a
video podcast but what does quality mean
well hopefully you're learning something
it's valuable you walk away with the
impression that my time wasn't wasted my
uh I learned something new I can apply
it to my channel and so there's
different definitions of quality and
quantity but here's the punch line the
reason we're able to upload all of that
content now across platforms is a team
thing is a system thing it's because
there's revenues that have been
generated at the business that are
ultimately able to be applied to the
content we're producing and when I heard
Alex tremozzi break down these three
phases that's what him and Layla are
doing at a whole nother level at
acquisition.com his head of production I
think is his title Caleb Rawson is
actually a friend of mine we go way back
to a small town an hour north of Seattle
Washington and we actually grew up doing
video together and our local church and
I remember when we first Gary vaynerchuk
came to Bellingham Washington and he
came on one of our channels back in the
day and Kayla was like a videographer we
hired at the time he was a videographer
for Gary V for a while and now he works
for Alex and Layla but the punch line is
I think they are spending something like
100 to 125 to 150 000 a month on content
creation that is being invested in
editors and strategists and people that
are focused on each individual platforms
and from an entrepreneurial mindset this
might be hard for some of us to relate
to but it makes a lot of sense from a
business owner standpoint especially
when you're doing something at the scale
that they're doing phase three is how
can we not just do quality but also
increase the quantity through leverage
what's leverage it means that I'm able
to hire somebody else use tools use
people use systems to multiply quality
content not just across YouTube but
across all the platforms so which phase
are you in are you in phase one where
it's about quantity and learning skills
phase two where it's about quality and
maybe doubling down and putting out some
bangers that can really grow your brand
or phase three where you're ultimately
doing both and maybe which phase could
you get to because it's time to make a
pivot it's time to maybe invest some
dollars hire an editor Outsource some
things lean into some AI software learn
into some things that could take your
long form and you know multiply it more
in short form I honestly think and I'm
curious your feedback that this is the
definite answer which one is most
important on YouTube well it depends
which phase you're in if you got value
out of this episode it would mean the
world to me if you like rate or review
the podcast wherever you watch or listen
to it and if you actually want to learn
more about the perfect video recipe that
will help you increase the quality of
your videos we have a free video series
here on the think media podcast that
will link up on the show notes or if
you're on the YouTube version just click
or tap the YouTube end card appreciate
you so much sending you love and respect
and we will talk soon